sechste runde beginnt zwei spieler
verbleiben dass das finale leute drücken
wir die daumen drückt mir die daumen und
ich spreche jetzt an was ich ansprechen
wollte was kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einem turnier auf kino.de wir haben
heute uns hier versammelt mit 40 leuten
und spielen gegeneinander diesem turnier
und die ein erster gegner skate kraft 01
der rasiert am markt
und ich habe gerade im schon an turnier
abbrechen müssen wir die lecks zu krass
waren aber ich hoffe auf dem server geht
es hier wieder der frist auf jeden fall
schon mal ordentlich hier und wieder
frisst hat mir gut das es gegeben aber
dürfte jetzt auch nicht weg sein spezial
sehr gut leute direkt vorweg zwei sachen
will ich ansprechen und zwar als
allererstes wird heute abend wieder ein
live stream geben so wie in den letzten
drei oder zwei arten auch jetzt zwei
oder drei abenden folge stream kanal und
können reinschreiben unten ich weiß gar
nicht genau
die zweite sache ist es gibt eine
relativ wichtige sache nicht mitteilen
möchte das werde ich voraussichtlich
irgendwann so am ende des videos machen
es geht um eine angelegenheit die ich
jetzt vor ein paar timer angesprochen
hatte dazu gibt's neuigkeiten nämlich zu
einer knochenmarkspende sag jetzt mal so
direkt dazu werde ich mich am ende mehr
erzählen
das heißt alle die das interessierte
können gerne dran bleiben und der rest
natürlich auch ich werde weiter so
verfahren dass ich glaube ich dass hier
raus hatte und deswegen springen wir
jetzt sofort zum nächsten kampf
da sind wir wieder kampf numero zwei der
sound ist so unfassbar laut in meinen
ohren nicht aber den einfach an dem
nachnamen leiser machen stelle ist es
nicht jetzt wo sonst gibt es nachher die
große verwirrung auf welches level die
das erstellen soll
er hat in seinen hits ist vielleicht gar
keine so gute sache für ihn
kompakt links rechts links rechts combo
motombo ich springe dilaver wie kann man
so ein bastard sein
jo jetzt gas geben vorfall stand gilt
mein gott war das knapp alte schwede
jetzt einfach nur weg laufen müssen
ihren gewalt das klappt das war glatt
das war richtig glatt blatt the game was
mir gerade eingefallen ist seit doch so
gut und schreibt mal unten in die
kommentare rein ob ihr euch auch selbst
anzünden würde in einer runde
wie schreibt man die kommentare rein was
ihr davon halte dass man diese runde
dieses die kämpfe der anderen drin lässt
wollt ihr das sehen oder nicht oder
essen der luxair brennt wie eine mutter
vater oder hat sich da selbst
vorgesetzter kassierte deftig und hat
mir den rat gegeben glaubt oder uns
beiden
ja ja ja sehr gut ohne einhaltung
einzusetzen passt als perfektes make a
là là
doch weiter so kommentiert dass wir so
ein bisschen hier unten den kampf von
captain red arrow ich glaube sonst wird
es zu kurz mit einem turnier der wärme
noch zehn spieler das wird definitiv zu
kurz genitiv das so hier
kerpen red arrows laser auf vier
ausgaben wie muss jetzt auf gleich
wieder dran seid ja sind wir auch also
schreibt unten rein wollte die kämpfe
sehen oder nicht
jetzt kommt jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen den vergleich dadurch durch das
jetzt löcher kommentieren werde
für den rest des turniers insofern ich
jetzt nicht schon gegen zocker
rausfliege hier der ist
ich habe noch was überlegt für heute
abend und zwar wird zudem in stream
heute abend muss erst mal platt dj geben
welches bis dahin eingerichtet bekomme
das heißt praktiker-papiere scannt
schreibt können einen kommentar
schreiben
praktika ich weiß gar nicht wie
verbreitet das ist das ist eine sache ob
ich kann überhaupt nicht kommen erzählen
hier warum so fragt dj ist und da kann
kann die ganze community die musik
bestimmt mit spielen die in meinem
stream ist und ich persönlich kann auch
ein bisschen diese anhalt der einsätze
an musste ich nicht sehr gut
also praktisch er voraussichtlich heute
abend im stümer auch mit dabei ich habe
mir generell super sachen überlegt und
werde mir ein paar sachen überlegen mit
dem wir so unsere streams demnächst
bisschen noch cooler gestalten können
oder bisschen aufpeppen können
das wird auch im fall richtig doof heute
abend geht es dann wieder rund gaming
gaming aos keine hau ist gaming mouse
irgendwie cooler name feiere ich unter
den optikern cape der andere nicht ich
bin natürlich oft definitiv auf der
seite von mobb deep ein bruder der ja
auch rumspringt wie ein kaninchen auf
credit halama gesetzt von florian häuser
oder kassiert richtig war und heute
passiert er mit sieben herzen verloren
da anhalt gewonnen mit 7 märz mit dem
herzen kann man verlieren in der regel
film mit 0 ercen aber gut es geht hier
weiter wissen
captain red arrow und sein kollege ist
da wir sind mit dem wasser abzeichen
aber der andere bearbeitete mit dem
bauerngut ärzteschaft auch ganz gut wenn
ich im wasser gefangen
und der kampf änderten zehn sekunden so
jetzt die frage wessen der mitte beide
stellen sich irgendwie nicht wirklich
dahin bestplatzierte zwar gut sechste
runde beginn zwei spieler verbleiben
dass das finale leute drücken wir die
daumen drückt mir die daumen und ich
spreche jetzt an was ich ansprechen
wollte ich habe heute den brief von der
dkms bekommen ich bin zu knopf zur
knochenmarkspende zugelassen und werde
am 21
spenden so das heißt es ist ein grünes
licht gegeben
ich darf spenden und ich treffe keine
pfeil den bastard alter an der macht
nicht viel spaß gefühle kommen jetzt
frisst frist ja das schöne alte wir die
lama passiert hat richtig gut scheiße
scheiße scheiße scheiße alter wie hatte
die larven da er so in die luft gesetzt
ras dschedir mal die kommentare wie man
da so die lava in die luft setzen konnte
oder wahrscheinlich einem blog alter das
wie weit das tier möglich naja gut hatte
auf jeden fall sehr gut gemacht die wie
gesagt habe ich schon geschrieben habe
ich schon geschrieben alles klar
ja leute knochenmarkspende grünes licht
wie gesagt in am 21 geht's los
ich werde mir übermorgen am 17 das erste
mal die medikamente spritzen und dann
auch mit dem blog anfangen und berichten
wie das so ist
vielleicht dokumentieren ich mir das
spritze in meinen geilen bauchspeck das
war's von heute versuche gefallen
wir sehen uns hoffentlich wird aber im
stream
der link wird dann wieder gepostet in
einem ansage video auf youtube ihr bis
dahin hat rein macht es gut und